ukrainian soldiers practiced their
drills near crimea almost eight years
ago the peninsula was annexed by russia
now many here and across europe fear
another act of aggression and the u.s
president says he thinks it will happen
on thursday in berlin joe biden's
secretary of state spelt out what the
west's reaction would be we have been
very clear throughout
if any russian military forces
move
across the ukrainian border and
commit new acts of aggression against
ukraine
that will be met
with a swift
severe united response
from the united states and
our allies and partners
and yet pictures like these from rostov
show russia increasing not decreasing
its military readiness
some media reports suggest forces like
these and many others are now poised at
several strategic locations around the
borders with ukraine
in moscow the view is very different
at the moment the western and ukrainian
media as well as officials have become
even more active in replicating
speculation about the imminent russian
invasion of ukraine as they put it we
are convinced that the goal of this
campaign is to create an information
cover for staging large-scale
provocations of their own including
those of military character which may
have extremely tragic consequences for
regional and global security
while in kiev president vladimir
zeliensky says his country's aim is to
prevent war with its neighbor
we do our best to find a diplomatic
solution we do our best for peace in
ukraine what should you do only one
thing don't panic keep your head cool be
self-confident be confident in our army
and our ukraine
here in the german capital ministers are
clear they say they want the russians to
de-escalate the situation even a tiny
step backwards would be a welcome step
but that any act of aggression would
have dire economic consequences for
russia
even if that would also cost germany
dearly
dominic kane al jazeera berlin
well let's get the view from both kiev
and moscow on those developments from al
jazeera correspondents who are there
ukrainians have been closely monitoring
the flurry of diplomatic efforts over
the past few weeks as this crisis has
been deepening after all this is a
conflict that has cost this country more
than 14 000 lives and add to that
more than 1.4 million people who are
internally displaced but beyond that you
don't get the feeling that people are
worried about an imminent russian
invasion despite all the rhetoric they
hear about from their own leadership or
indeed european and american politicians
now people will tell you that this is
actually not the right time for russia
to
cross the border they say that the
situation is different than back in 2014
they say that the army the ukrainian
army now is much more capable is much
better equipped it has received uh
training so they feel that they are much
more confident now and that russia knows
exactly that
russia's foreign ministry is very clear
about what they're hoping to achieve
from the meeting on friday in geneva
that is they want to take the next steps
on negotiations on security guarantees
that they're asking the american
government about the possibility of nato
expanding further eastwards as well as
not allowing ukraine to join the
military alliance that is something that
is very much a red line for this country
so that's the official position here but
what do ordinary russians think about
the ongoing tensions we asked some
people here in the capital and here's
what they had to say
i think there will be no war
it seems to me that we have this
situation from time to time because
authorities need to keep people up with
something apart from covet putin's
rating is just going down
i don't believe it's possible that
brotherly nations will ever start this
war i wouldn't want it because why what
for to prove what and to whom i stand
for peace
why is it all needed i wish we don't
make war especially with ukraine we are
brothers indeed that's all i can tell
you
as the world waits to find out what
happens in geneva on friday many here
are hoping that diplomacy and dialogue
can continue to be the path forward to
try and de-escalate the looming crisis